[Musik]
am 24 mai 2005 stürmen rund ein dutzend
steuerbeamte diese treppe hoch sie
brechen die türe ein und durchsuchen die
geschäftsräume
[Musik]
es sind die lokalitäten des ubs-kunden
igor olenicoff
hier ist der raum wo ich meine
geschäftsunterlagen aufbewahren
und hier sind meine persönlichen
bankunterlagen in diesem feuersicheren
safe
die beamten wussten genau wonach sie
suchten
nämlich meine unterlagen über die
offshore konten bei der ubs und der neue
bank
bekannt neu bekannt
der folgende film zeigt wie die
grossbank ubs an den rand des abgrunds
gerät weil sie in den usa mit einem
illegalen steuersparmodelle arbeitet
der film zeigt wie der amerikanische
staat schonungslos dagegen vorgeht er
braucht geld um die folgen der
wirtschaftskrise zu bezahlen
der bundesrat und was geht
und der film zeigt ließ der schweizer
regierung gelingt im letzten moment das
schlimmste abzuwenden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
begonnen hat alles am 7 november 2000
der damalige bundesrat kaspar villiger
autorisiert die schweizer banken mit den
usa den so genannten qi den collie fight
in dem mietvertrag abzuschließen
der finanzplatz zürich ist zufrieden der
vertrag regelt die beziehungen der
banken zur amerikanischen steuerbehörde
jetzt kann man im us-markt wachsen ja
kein vertrag spielt eine schlüsselrolle
in dieser geschichte der damalige ubs
chef marcel ospel steht zu diesem
zeitpunkt unter druck die grossbank gilt
als zu risikoscheu im us markt sieht er
seine chance wir wollen unser
privatkundengeschäft
international ausbauen die euro
lastigkeit etwas ausbalancieren der
folgende film zeigt wie die ubs
ausgerechnet über diesen amerikanischen
markt stolpern wird
weil eine ubs abteilung mit illegalen
steuer spart den vertrag um geht
angeblich verantwortlich der ubs banker
martin liechti er wird deswegen vor dem
amerikanischen parlament erscheinen
müssen
auf hartmanns anwalts verweigere ich
gestützt auf die amerikanische
verfassung die antwort auf ihre frage
licht die wiederum wäsche von bradley
birkenfeld dem späteren kronzeugen der
amerikanischen anklage
martini wollte jäger haben und wollte
leute haben die aggressiv den markt
angehen und ich kann mich noch erinnern
welche vorgestellt hat und gesagt hat ja
den haben wir an bord geholt der will
die welt erobern und den wollen wir
dabei haben
und bradley birkenfeld wiederum brachte
einen kunden zu ubs er ebenfalls eine
hauptrolle spielen wird igor olenicoff
das ist eine erinnerung an glücklichere
tage es ist ein geschenk der ubs
sie hat auf die kuhglocke den namen
meiner yacht eingravieren lassen
eine erinnerung an einen ausflug den ubs
manager mit mir auf einer yacht machten
der amerikanische milliardär igor
olenicoff
er legt millionen in illegalen ubs
steuerstrukturen an auf rat des
ubs-kunden betreuers bradley birkenfeld
birkenfeld verbrachte mehrere
wochenenden hier mit mir er aß brot von
diesem tisch und trank wein
es ist beschämend herauszufinden dass
jemand so falsch sein kann
der steuerbetrug beginnt am vierten juli
2000 eine streng vertrauliche diskussion
von ubs manager sie überlegen wie sie
außerhalb des kaufvertrages geschäften
könnten
[Musik]
unter dem neuen vertrag müssen die
banken nämlich melden wie viele us
wertschriften ihre amerikanischen kunden
besitzen und zwar direkt an die us
steuerbehörde
die nun diese meldepflicht aushebeln das
prüfen ubs-manager in diesem internen
memorandum
der trick zwischen kunde und bank eine
briefkastenfirma setzen zum beispiel auf
den bahamas dann sei der kontoinhaber
nicht mehr amerikaner ihr vertrag gelte
nicht mehr eine meldung an die
us-steuerbehörde angeblich nicht mehr
nötig
[Musik]
illegal notieren die banker zwar eine
aktive beihilfe zur steuerflucht laut
us-gesetz ein kriminelles delikt
der raffinierte ausweg externe von der
ubs ausgewählte berater sollen die
briefkasten struktur gründen doch auch
das ist illegal
wer wusste in der ub ist davon die ubs
verweigert interviews und schreibt
generell sie gebe keine stellungnahme ab
bis der fall vollständig abgeschlossen
sei
adressat des entwurfs ist das business
community private banking
im komitee sitzt raul weil später
mitglied der obersten konzernleitung no
comment lässt er auf die frage
ausrichten ob er den entwurf gesehen
habe auch dabei sei es gäbe bereits
damals mitglied der obersten ubs
konzernleitung genehmigte also sogar die
konzernleitung die legalen steuertricks
scania war hier eine archivaufnahme
erklärt heute er habe ein solches papier
nie gesehen
[Musik]
dass wo modell gemacht hat den usa mit
wüsste geschäfte dass ich nicht so lieb
und das verurteilen und ich glaube dass
ich einfach so im nachhinein einen
schalen geschmack panther wird
ich bin schockiert ich finde das
verhalten inakzeptabel es hat sowohl dem
finanzplatz als auch den ubs
angestellten und auch der ubs geschadet
igor olenicoff
transferiert ein teil seines geldes in
solche steuer spar strukturen
ubs-kundenberater birkenfeld koordiniert
das ganze
wirken verkrieche mich an und sagte mir
jetzt sei der moment gekommen wo ich
mein geld transferieren solle er schlug
vor ich soll es zur ubs can verschieben
zuerst transferierte ich nur einen teil
ich legte eine tranche von 60 millionen
dollar an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn vierter juli 2001 die amerikaner in
der schweiz feiern den nationalfeiertag
unter ihnen der banker der in dieser
geschichte eine hauptrolle spielen wird
bradley birkenfeld
es ist dann sehr patriotische momente
uns amerikaner und gleichzeitig freuen
wir uns in der schweiz zusammen
[Musik]
im ubs ausbildungszentrum wolfsberg
schuh die grossbank ihre mitarbeiter
einer der referenten ist udo hamm er
lernt hier birkenfeld kennen
bei dem ganzen auditorium gab es nur
sehr wenige leute die überhaupt den mut
hatten oder die die fassungen hatten zu
sagen dass wir etwas tun müssten und er
war einer der konstant ideen hatten die
man angehen sollte also ein sehr
dynamischer und aktive persönlichkeit so
habe ich ihn kennengelernt haben
natürlich geschmunzelt das sinntal den
ganz vielen die da dann säße ich waren
nur eine handvoll von leuten überhaupt
ideen haben wie sie wie sie morgen
erobern wollen die meisten waren damit
beschäftigt gestern zu zelebrieren und
heute erst mal nichts zu tun
im januar 2002 übernimmt martin licht
die die ubs abteilung nordamerika die
illegalen steuersparmodelle
mischer banker er hatte erkannt dass er
neue neue vorgehensweisen definieren
muss um anmerkt heranzukommen die heute
nicht hat
und das war progressiv oder aggressiv je
nachdem wie man das bezeichnen will und
hat dann die möglichkeiten geschaffen
dass wir neue leute kennen lernen also
was können wir neu machen um aufzufallen
und diese diese freiheiten diesen raum
hatte martin die gewährt
udo hamm damals im team von martin
liechti ist experte für die entwicklung
von strategien zur kundenakquisition
erstmals spricht er über seine tätigkeit
in den usa
opposition hat vielleicht zwei phasen
das eine ist das kennenlernen
beziehungen aufbauen und das zweite ist
dann das sailing aber man kann niemandem
was verkaufen den man nicht kennt also
muss man den ersten schritt machen um
den zweiten machen zu können die
professionalität besteht haben zu
erkennen wie verhält sich diese gruppe
die wir erobern wollen um dann zu sagen
okay das sind die kleider die wir
mitnehmen diese badehose nehmen wir mit
warum weil die auf den bildern der
vergangenen jahren sieht das ja so aus
also dementsprechend müssen wir uns
schon mal so kleiden damit wir
kompatibel sind mit dieser zielgruppe
das war unsere aufgabe und die leute die
dort mitgegangen sind unter anderem hat
er breitet er war sehr gut dabei
miami florida
viele reiche amerikaner besuchen die
kunstmesse art basel miami die messe zum
jagdgebiet für die ubs abteilung
nordamerika
und dann die leute heranholen einladen
bewirten unterhaltsam sein das sind die
faktoren die dann eine beziehung
ermöglichen und alles weitere entsteht
dann aus der beziehung und die banker
die dann abgestellt waren die waren dazu
da in aller erster instanz beziehungen
aufzubauen um dann in der folge zu
schauen wo sie ihre geschäfte tätigen
können da werden dann auch keine fahnen
von meinem arbeitgeber sondern das ist
dann wirklich ein privater rahmen so
wird er dann wahrgenommen ja und dann
habe ich die leute angerufen und gebeten
ob sie mir häuser zur verfügung stellen
um dort privat dinners oder privat
partys zu machen je nach grad des
empfängers etwas mehr trennen die partys
wenn es hier leute unter 40 watt
[Musik]
und wenn es weit über 50 wurde über 60
waren dann waren das halt gesetzte
dinners mit dokumenten
gesprächsteilnehmer dann habe ich die
familie kennedy mobilisieren kann dass
sie ihr haus zur verfügung stellen um
dann aus aller welt kunst blieben die
leute zusammenbringen zu können in einem
privaten rahmen und die ubs hat er dann
ein paar
vertreter eingeladen der firma die dann
entsprechend dieser klientel sich
anpassen können
bis dahin ist alles legal jetzt erst
passiert es die ubs kundenberater
beginnen über banking zu sprechen locken
mit umstrittenen steuertricks
und geben den so hunderte von neuen
kunden in zahlreichen mails waren sich
die ubs leute achtung undercover aktion
in der amerikanischen steuerbehörden
heißt es beispielsweise hier
sensitive heikel sei das thema heißt es
anderswo
[Musik]
und abteilungsleiter martin licht die
warnt vor schriftlichen spuren
[Musik]
vertrauliche sitzung der ubs ag im
januar 2002
die direktion lässt sich über die
strengen us bestimmungen unter dem
kaufvertrag orientieren die direktorin
erfahren ubs-banker dürfen ihre kunden
in den usa nur anrufen wenn der kunde
das vermögen versteuert
[Musik]
das gleiche gilt für kundenbesuche
besucher bei kunden die ihr vermögen
nicht deklarieren sind verboten
eigentlich das ende der illegalen steuer
spart
[Musik]
der dcn unter anderem marcel rohner und
stephan haeringer so zeigt dieses ubs
dokument zu finden in den amerikanischen
gerichtsakten
die beiden führen später mit marcel
ospel zusammen die ubs
die spitzenmanager verschärfen zwar
danach die vorgaben kundenbesuche nur
noch ausnahmsweise verlangen sie doch
keiner kontrolliert die einhaltung
und offenbar fragt keiner den
abteilungsleiter martin liechti wie er
in den usa genau geschäftet keiner
hinterfragt das profitable geschäft die
top manager erklären später sie hätten
damals nichts von den illegalen steuer
spart
die hier zur debatte stehen die
schweizer bank kam in die usa
akquirierte hier aktiv kunden und half
ihnen heimlich die usa zu betrügen die
ubs hat ihr fehlverhalten eingestanden
und erklärte vor gericht sie habe ich
zitiere wissentlich an einem system
mitgewirkt dessen ziel es war die usa
und ihre steuerbehörde zu betrügen
ich möchte dass nochmals vorlesen
die ubs an ihr kennt ihr fehlverhalten
und sagte vor gericht sie habe zitat
wissentlich an einem system mitgewirkt
dessen ziel es war die usa und ihre
steuerbehörde zu betrieben
die ubs trainierte ihre rund 50 us
kunden berater gezielt darauf den
amerikanischen gesetzen auszuweichen
auszüge aus ubs papieren in den
gerichtsakten
falls sie sich durch das fbi beobachtet
fühlen wie reagieren sie heißt es hier
wechseln sie häufig das hotel wird
geraten
[Musik]
nur leere laptops kein papier mit ubs
aufdrucke keine spuren hinterlassen
und wenn man erwischt wird keine panik
eine notfallnummer ist bereit 24 stunden
sieben tage die woche
[Musik]
3800 solch illegaler kundenbesuche
absolvierten ubs-kundenberater
beispielsweise im jahre 2004
sogar einen eigenen geheimcode hatte die
abteilung entwickelt orange für euro
grün für dollar und blau färbt und
so verschlüsselt wird mit den us kunden
kommuniziert
staatsanwalt john di cicco erläutert
später dem senatsausschuss das ergebnis
seiner ermittlungen
die ubs nutzte verschiedene strategien
um ihre aktivitäten zu verbergen sie
wies ihre bänke an bei ihrer ankunft
fälschlicherweise anzugeben zu urlaubs
zwecken einzureisen sie empfahl den
bankern auch regelmäßig das hotel zu
wechseln um nicht entdeckt zu werden die
ubs banker warnten spionage methoden an
wie etwa verschlüsselte tabellen so
wollten sie vermeiden dass ihre
marketing methoden und die identität der
us-kunden mit unversteuertem geld
entdeckt würden
[Musik]
dann am 24
mai 2005 der erste riss im illegalen ubs
system die hausdurchsuchung bei igor
olenicoff
[Musik]
aber es war sehr besorgt darüber dass
gegen mich ermittelt wurde und mein
unterlagen durchsucht worden waren
sie waren besorgt darüber dass die
us-regierung nicht ins visier nahm
in der ubs abteilung nordamerika kriegt
man kalte füße laut amerikanischen
gerichtsakten schlägt martin licht die
im jahre 2006 vor ganz aus dem us
geschäft auszusteigen die ubs
konzernspitze zögert und entscheidet
sich erst ein jahr später für den
ausstieg
verwaltungsratspräsident peter kurer
wird dies später so darstellen sie haben
mir die frage gestellt warum dass wir
auf der ebene verwaltungsrat und
konzernleitung
nichts gewusst haben von diesen
staatshilfe zu steuerbetrug wenn wir das
so nennen wollen die antwort ist wie
folgt dieser bereich betraf eine kleine
geschäftseinheit die insgesamt
weniger wie ein halbes prozent des
umsatzes des gesamtunternehmens
generierte und deshalb diese sachen
relativ lange unter verschluss
halten konnte in dem moment wo das
erkannt wurde wo die eingeschritten
[Musik]
nach der hausdurchsuchung fährt
birkenfeld mit olenicoff nach vaduz
das geld wird unplatziert weg von der
ubs zur neuen bank
es wäre einfach sicherer mein geld nach
liechtenstein zu transferieren
das geld sei dort besser abgeschottet
gegen mögliche folgen diese durchsuchung
dieser transfer wird birkenfeld später
in den usa zum verhängnis die genfer
wohnung von bradley birkenfeld
wenige tage nach dem transfer der
olenicoff gelder kündigte er bei der ubs
er macht sich selbständig mit einer
genfer briefkastenfirma namens julian
charter
hier im vierten stock ist diese
domiziliert hier verwaltet er jetzt
angeblich die olenicoff millionen nach
der kündigung streitet er mit der ubs
wegen seines bonus
irgendwie war da und hat pausenlos mit
leuten geredet oben um den brand ubs
weiter zu bringen um kunden zu gewinnen
das war seine einzige
daseinsberechtigung so diese art von
leuten setzten sich emotional 24 stunden
sieben tage die woche setzen die sich
ein um leute zu erobern und diese leute
sind äußerst empfindlich wenn man ihnen
den rücken fällt weil sie ja sehr weit
vorne sind und ein persönliches risiko
eingehen und er fühlte sich von ihr in
den rücken gefallen dass sie auf der
einen seite hohe ziele von ihm
abverlangt und auch bestraft wenn er
diese ziele nicht erreicht nämlich in
erster instanz mit nicht zahlung von
boni und in zweiter instanz mit
kündigungen drohen
doch die ubs bezahlt birkenfeld nur
einen teil seiner forderung
wenige wochen später juni 2007
birkenfeld reist nach washington
er informiert die us behörden über das
illegale ubs system doch er sagte mir
mittler nicht dass er die olenicoff
gelder nach wie vor verwaltet die
ermittler aber kombinieren ihre
erkenntnisse aus den brücken fällt
aussagen und der hausdurchsuchung
olenicoff wird einfallen die us-justiz
realisiert mit dem muster fall können
sie das ganze system aufholen
igor olenicoff streitet zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch jede schuld ab
[Musik]
da kontaktieren ihn die behörden mit
einem verlockenden angebot praktisch
keine strafe wenn er sich schuldig
bekennen
sie brauchten den sogenannten schneeball
der die lawine auslöst
sie mussten beweisen dass die usa zu
schaden kamen dass jemand der hätte
steuern bezahlen sollen dies nicht tat
und dass er dies nicht tat weil er das
geld im ausland auf einem offshore konto
versteckte
solange sie niemanden hatten der von
birkenfeld und der ubs profitiert hatten
sie keinen fall
ich wurde lediglich verurteilt weil ich
im jahr 2002 ein auslandskonto nicht
deklariert hatte weil ich damals in der
steuererklärung eine box nicht
angekreuzt hatte
die ganze anklage gegen mich
so dass ich bereit war mich dafür
schuldig zu bekennen konnten sie
birkenfeld anklagen und dann via
birkenfeld die ubs die us behörde war
nie wirklich an interessiert ihr fokus
war die ganze zeit auf die ubs gerichtet
das war der dicke fisch das ist
inzwischen klar
der olenicoff kombiniert mit den
birkenfeld aussagen ergibt das explosive
gemisch
aktenzeichen nummer 09 20 423
systematischer beihilfe zu steuerbetrug
belegt mit einem musterfall
zürich
das telefon klingelt beim schweizer
korrespondenten der financial times
simonian ich werde es nie vergessen es
war den 12 september 2007 und ich hatte
gerade ein fuß aus meint uhr hier im
büro als mein telefon klingelte und wie
jeder journalist wahrscheinlich bin ich
zurück gegangen und habe aufgehoben und
da war er wegen seiner parteinahme hat
er nicht gegeben mein name ist orange
oder sagte das ist nicht meine wirkliche
name ich rufe von einer telefonkabine
aber was ich ihnen jetzt erzählen wir
werden wird mein leben in gefahr setzen
und eventuell das ende der schweizer
bankgeheimnis heißen so hat das gesagt
was denken sie war die motivation von
reckenfeld also ich glaube rache spielte
eine rolle geld spielt eventuell eine
rolle jetzt laut amerikanischen
gesetzt hat eine rüssel dauer jemand der
infos gibt über steuersünder hat er das
recht bis zu 30 prozent des geldes für
sich selbst als belohnung zu bekommen
doch die erhofften müssen blauer gelder
gibt es wohl nicht birkenfeld wird wegen
beihilfe zu steuerbetrug zu dreieinhalb
jahren gefängnis verurteilt
der grund birkenfeld verheimlichte dass
er nach seiner ubs kündigung olenicoffs
illegale steuerstrukturen weiter
betreute das wird ihm vor gericht zum
verhängnis
die neue bank in vaduz
hierhin bringt olenicoff auf burgen fels
rat die steuer konstrukte die neue bank
will vor der kamera nicht stellung
nehmen sie schreibt wegen des
bankgeheimnisses könnte sie keine fragen
zu konnte beziehungen beantworten die
neue bank betont sie biete von sich aus
keine solchen strukturen an und sie legt
wert auf die feststellung dass sie stets
alle gesetze und standesregeln
eingehalten habe
zur gleichen zeit in den usa tausende
von fabriken werden geschlossen
eine beispiellose wirtschaftskrise die
jagd nach steuersündern erhält eine neue
dimension
[Musik]
[Applaus]
23 dezember 2008
4000 leute ohne job unter ihnen camp ley
ich mache alles was ich kann ich habe
ein gutes bewerbungsdossier und viele
kontakte aber jetzt gehen wir die mittel
aus ich habe kein internet mehr muss in
die bibliothek gehen zu melden es ist
ein harter job arbeit zu finden
millionen kämpfen um ihre existenz
und so erhält der kampf gegen
steuerflucht jetzt vorrang
der staatsanwalt der zuständig ist für
die ubs akte
in einer zeit in der millionen von
amerikaner ihren arbeitsplatz ihre
häuser und ihre krankenversicherung
verlieren ist es empörend zu sehen wie
die reichsten hinter uns versucht haben
die geschuldeten steuern nicht zu
bezahlen das erste parlament wird unsere
steuerbehörde jede unterstützung
zukommen lassen damit diese jene
lokalisieren und gemäß unseren gesetzen
zur verantwortung ziehen können
[Musik]
in der autostadt detroit vor kurzem
spielten ja noch kinder auf der straße
jetzt sind bis auf drei häuser alle leer
120 häuser zerstört
solche bilder erklären die ungeduld mit
der die amerikanische justiz von der
schweiz auskunft über die ubs verlangt
in einem der häuser wohnt fatima
mohammed noch denn auch sie will weg
ziehen
ich kann es schon gar nicht mehr ansehen
so beschämt bin ich schrecklich
ich hasse es sorgen zu müssen dass ich
in dieser gegend tun all dies geschah in
den letzten drei jahren vorher war diese
straße sehr schön überall spielen kinder
wegen der wirtschaftlichen situation
verzweifelten viele leute und brannten
ihre häuser so konnten sie die
versicherungsleistungen einkassieren und
wegziehen
anderen eben alles was rühren fenster
und verkaufen ist
ist man mal zwei tage nicht zu hause ist
alles weg
die polizei versucht zu verhindern dass
verlassene häuser besetzt werden
meist vergeblich
da haben heute versucht das haus zu
besitzen hier die matratze
sie wollten übernachten
vielleicht gingen sie kriminellen
aktivitäten nach
[Musik]
die neue dimension erklärt den eifer der
us-justiz möglichst schnell viele ubs
steuersünder zu ermitteln der chef der
amerikanischen steuerbehörde irs vor dem
us senatsausschuss
wenn das amerikanische volk konfrontiert
ist mit geschichten über finanzinstitute
die amerikanischen bürgern halfen ihr
geld im ausland in betrügerischen
strukturen zu verstecken damit sie keine
steuern zahlen müssen dann ist es
schockiert so wie ich es bin und sie
sind es sich auch
bern achter märz 2008 seit einem halben
jahr ermitteln die us-behörden bereits
jetzt erreicht die akte ubs bundesbank
urs zulauf von der bankenaufsicht finma
erhält einen anruf von der ubs
konzentriere mich auf das letztlich
entscheiden sie im märz 2008
dass sie
das amerikanische staat also wohl im die
partner justin angestellte ist ein
untersuche geführt
und dass
kundendaten von der ubs über und das
youtube spot mit dem 2cv die uns
herausgefordert
wer im beruf reagiert für uns ist das
extrem
[Musik]
ansteigt
es ist absolut klar dass dies auch als
sehr großes potenzial hat
florida 22 april 2008 die polizei nimmt
dem flugzeug den mann fest der die
umstrittene ubs abteilung leitet martin
liechti er ist auf dem weg von new york
auf die bahamas
der fall ubs eskaliert
[Musik]
bradley birkenfeld behauptete später er
habe die us justiz über martin licht die
informiert
birkenfeld ruft haig simonian an
es war ein späten nachmittag nicht zu
weit von redaktionsschluss kommt ein
anruf hey sie wissen es nicht aber ich
habe das jetzt herausgefunden vor ein
paar tagen des folgendes passiert
herrlich war in miami er war unterwegs
von ein termin zu einem anderen termin
und er ist dann von den behörden
gestoppt worden
macht ihr licht die wird im hotel four
seasons in miami als zeuge festgehalten
mit elektronischen fußfesseln
in den usa wird beihilfe zu steuerbetrug
mit vielen jahren gefängnis geahndet
martin liechti ist bereit auszusagen
gleichzeitig liefert jetzt die ubs
tausende von dokumenten an die us-justiz
vier monate lang wird licht die im hotel
festgehalten dann darf ausreisen als
freier mann
die bank ubs hingegen wirklich die nie
mehr betreten dürfen
der stabilität natürlich sie der
verhaftung
maßgebende lüthi der ubs rechtsfall wo
man merkt es gilt ernst es blitzt und
donnert
auch um hätten das recht ist war für
ihre was sarah wiener das noch der hund
und ich glaube sehr schmal
so richtig alarm stimmig heim er
überholt denn im juli wo das erste
amtshilfegesuch gysi kam nicht nachdem
offensichtlich die amerikanische
steuerbehörde vorher schon mehrere monat
mit der ubs selber in kontakt gestanden
ist einmal gemerkt jetzt gott bin
richtig bunt jetzt sind richtig gehört
jetzt gott sein richtig auf der
steuerverwaltung wo führt abwickelt vor
amtshilfegesuch verantwortlich ist
bern sommer 2008 die schweizer behörden
sind endlich zehn monate nach dem
amerikanischen ermittlungs start in
intensivem kontakt mit den usa die
us-justiz reicht ein amtshilfegesuch ein
hat aber bald den eindruck die schweiz
war das ein zuwachs durch die behandlung
fordern
ist er intensiv betrieben oder im
rückblick aber muss man sagen leider
nicht schneit nur und die haben einfach
nachhaltige laufenden untersuchungen
kann um das ist quasi
das heute vom mitte oktober 2000 und
auch da
dass die amerikanischen behörden bereits
sieben öffentlich
mittelpunkt treten wenn nicht vorher
sie hält es klipp und klar
[Musik]
ich bin eine krankheitsbedingte wochen
ausgefallen und zwar bis ein drittel
november und kurz nachdem die hand frau
widmer-schlumpf also stets ministerin
und die ich als finanzminister gemeinsam
ein brief an die justiz
departements verursacht richtet und
hinter dieser ausdruck geben die ganze
entwicklung und die zusammenarbeit
offeriert
dennoch eskaliert der fall weiter die
usa klappt wenige tage später am 12
november 2008 die oberste führungsspitze
der ubs an
namentlich genannt wird einzig raul weil
der chef von martin lichte
die auch vom raul weil ich interessant
helsper tag vorteile nach
erfahren dass ein schritt verrückt und
mit dem moment hätte
politische stufe eine intervention
erfolgt oder die amerikanische regierung
und trotzdem ist die anlage erfolgt als
wir bei herrn wahl waren dann waren wir
wirklich auf den großen fischen und das
war dann ja auch einigermaßen bedrohlich
für die ubs weil es wurde nicht nur raul
weil angeklagt sondern in der
anklageschrift gibt es auch ein verweis
der wirklich die person von peter kohl
ziemlich genau anschaut so ist es
ehrmann sprach von annähernd
konzertes ohne zu sagen wer diese leute
war aber die vermutung für alle die was
mit dem fall zu tun hatten waren
natürlich ja die leute in der ersten
etage der ubs zum beispiel peter kohl
zum beispiel peter kurer und marcel
rohner
es ist die zeit nach dem zusammenbruch
der amerikanischen bank lehman brothers
das globale finanzsystem steht vor dem
kollaps
trotzdem ermittelt die us justiz
weiterhin intensiv gegen die grossbank
ubs
[Musik]
die dann die punkt kommt aus amerika
über verschiedene die information dass
wenn es nicht möglich ist rasch 100 und
rasch das ist anfangs sei es
im prinzip bis 1 jahr oder so what would
end ist patricks das ist rolle genau das
zu 100 über oder falls irgend so ein
arrangement das
nach lage
bank erfolgt
dezember 2008 in bern stellt die sorge
eine anklage direkt gegen die bank und
nicht mehr gegen einzelpersonen wäre
dramatisch
unternehmen wie es natürlich mehr
rechenschaft abgeben was das bedeutet
man hätte ja gewiss dass du bist eine
enorme bedeutung hat dieser
volkswirtschaft dass sie zehntausende
von kleineren und mittleren unternehmen
als kunden hätten kredit bedient dass
sie millionen von konnte head alone
konnte von mitarbeitern dafür
irgendwelchen unternehmen dass sie ihre
große rolle spielte im clearing also im
interbanken zahlungsverkehr und
präsentiert eine strafklage gegen die
ubs wäre extrem gefährlich gewesen die
ubs stellte ein systemisches risiko dar
nicht nur für die schweiz sondern auch
für die usa
überhaupt
nicht dass sie konkret
präzedenzfall
ganz prominente anderson nach einem nach
dem zusammenbruch verein rohren die siag
torte und die sie aus kobalt nickel
prüfgesellschaft mit über 130
angestellte
zerbrochen obschon sie nach zwei jahren
freigesprochen wurde das interessiert
nach einem nehmen und würde markt das
weiß dass das passiert diese überlegung
dass die bank sofort destabilisiert wird
dass der aktienkurs wird verbrecher der
sonne nach haag und das sofort massiv
und das bank unmittelbar sofort
integritäts schwierigkeiten er wirklich
kommt und deshalb ist stimmig sehr
besorgt sie dem linzer dezember sie mir
alle themen mit größter besorgnis zu
machen und deshalb ist der wunsch wo die
filme alle maßnahmen treffen wo geeignet
sind um das verhindere dass apple die
ubs letztlich in die anklage ihnen
trottet
die finma die bankenaufsicht sucht in
den weihnachtstagen
intensiv nach einer lösung
im handy treffen trägern kunstverein was
da im hintergrund
das bedeutet
die
situation
in bern sitzen die verantwortlichen wie
auf nadeln die öffentlichkeit darf
nichts erfahren von der drohenden
anklage und den vergleichsverhandlungen
doch die us-justiz fertige durch
senator levin erklärt später
von den
52.000 ubs konti und den geschätzten
19.000 us kunden raten sie wie viele us
kunden nahmen die schweiz unter der
bestehenden rechtsordnung bereit war und
zu übermitteln
und gesagt so etwas fertig jetzt weiter
mir nehme wir werden innert tagen werde
man das verfahren leiter mich eine datei
rücksicht auf irgendwelche verfahren und
das ist der moment wo denn zu einer
weiteren sondersitzung vom bundesrat
geführt hat am 19 februar die
krisensitzung
der bundesrat um was geht es
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen der große schock
die usa haben das bankgeheimnis geknackt
die schweiz übergibt rund 300
kundendossiers nur so kann jene anklage
vermieden werden die die ubs in den
abgrund reißen würde
[Musik]
die verfügung die gestern erlassen wurde
sieht vor dass die finma daten von
kunden der ubs bei denen gemäss der bank
verdacht auf steuerbetrug nach
schweizerischem recht besteht an das
department of justice herausgeben wird
[Musik]
es war ein schock für
diese traditionelle schweizer
bankgeheimnis niemand hätte erwartet
dass so was passieren würde und
vielleicht dazu um zu zeigen wie
ungewöhnlich und wie stark es war es ist
interessant wenn mit alle akteure
spricht niemand will da die
verantwortung haben wenn man die bank
fragt sagt die bank das hat mit uns
nichts zu tun dass es die firma die
finanzmarktbehörde was uns so geordnet
hat wenn man mit finma spricht sagt man
aber wir sind nur eine agentur eine
behörde der regierung wenn man mit
bundesräte spricht bespricht die sagen
aber das war finmas entscheidung
miami am gleichen tag die usa erreichen
jetzt statt strafklage zivilklage gegen
die ubs ein sie fordern 52.000
kundendaten das sogenannte john doe
summons -verfahren friesisch karg sie da
wirklich seit all die sache alle
elemente auseinandersetzung von teschen
alle inklusive die der herausgabe bevor
der amerikanische steuerbehörde john doe
summons
das ist nicht möglich gesetzlich
das ist nicht möglich sich über grünen
spekulieren aber es ist nicht nur blogs
die studie der krank macht das sind
nicht die
welt trug ziehen und im gegenteil sie
werden die gesetze vor gericht
der nächste schritt
verwaltungsratspräsident peter kurer
geht er ist ohne ihn signalisieren die
usa seien vergleichsverhandlungen
denkbar peter kurer bestreitet wird aber
vor der kamera nicht stellung nehmen
[Musik]
ich denke das war eine gute entscheidung
der bank
wer zu neuen ufern aufbrechen will der
muss im allgemeinen auch neue köpfe
präsentieren
es ist eine übliche lösung
s übernehmen alt bundesrat kaspar
villiger
und oswald grippe
unsere schweizer finanzplatz sind es
wert die meisten mitarbeiter der
nordamerika abteilung werden entlassen
eine neue ubs soll entstehen
miami dreizehnter juli der erste
gerichtstermin die ubs anwälte ziehen
sich zurück
die schweizer regierung hat sich
offiziell eingeschaltet die us-forderung
verletzte schweizer recht sagt sie
schwierige verhandlungen beginnen
eine grundsatzeinigung wurde am abend
meiner ankunft in washington erreicht
von der schweizer delegation die mit der
amerikanischen steuerbehörde verhandelt
das war am vorabend meines treffens mit
der amerikanischen außenministerin
und frau clinton und ich waren sehr
glücklich darüber
[Musik]
eine grundsatzeinigung wurde erreicht
es gibt eine einigung mit der schweizer
regierung und unsere regierung über den
andauernden streit bezüglich ubs
tobias
zu beginn
doch wegen den details drohen die
verhandlungen zu scheitern die
bundesrätin calmy-rey jetzt enthüllt
ich sag dann muss man hätte denken
können die details wären leicht
innerhalb einer sitzung zu lösen
nein die verhandlung über die und
details in anführungszeichen war nicht
leicht und ist im letzten moment noch
fast gescheitert
das letzte mal ist die schweizer
delegation nach washington reiste in der
letzten nach der verhandlung hat mich
mein staatssekretär ambühl nach vier
stunden verhandlungen angerufen und mir
gesagt die verhandlungen sind
unterbrochen
es ist sehr sehr schwierig ich weiß
nicht ob es gelingt
nachdem ich das telefon aufgehängt hatte
sagte ich mir wir haben hier ein großes
problem
ich muss ihn an den willen des
gesamtbundesrates erinnert ihm die
unterstützung der regierung zu sichern
und ich habe ihm eine sms geschickt mit
dem inhalt lassen sie nicht locker alles
gute
danach hat es noch rund zwölf stunden
verhandlungen gebraucht bis der
vergleich unter dach
der kompromiss lautet auslieferung von
weiteren kundendaten in rund 4450 fälle
und das innerhalb eines jahres
allerdings auf basis der bestehenden
schweizer rechtsordnung
meine damen und herren der bund hat sich
in den letzten monaten in einer nie
dagewesenen weise für ein unternehmen
engagiert er hat sehr hohe risiken in
kauf nehmen müssen um den
reputationsschaden den einzelne
vertreter der ubs dem finanzplatz und
damit den ganzen land zugefügt haben zu
minimieren will man drauf dass er
begrüße manipulationen gemacht worden
sind mit hunden wo banken sie wisse dass
die gesetzeswidrig sind und trotzdem
herz ist gemacht
der finanzplatz schweiz darf nicht als
ein ort wahrgenommen werden wo man
schmutziges geld versteckt das wollen
wir nicht das will der bundesrat nicht
und das war auch der grund für unseren
einsatz und ich denke dass jetzt
untersucht werden muss wer dafür
verantwortlich war und ich freue mich zu
hören dass die zürcher
staatsanwaltschaft diese frage prüft
[Musik]